GEMA we're here to talk about Game of
Thrones and I know you hadn't actually
heard about it when you first auditioned
how do you say what viruses have spies
everywhere now how did you what was your
first impression of the show that um my
first impression of the show having not
heard anything about it until I got the
the meeting it was just
I watched it back-to-back I watched the
whole of season one just I couldn't
gonna wait to get home so to watch the
whole season I think I watched the whole
season in two days and then I was hungry
for more just was fantastic it just
takes all the boxes doesn't it's great
yeah and what was it like when you were
the new girl on set with an established
career on there it was created because
myself and Patrick who plays Alfie night
my father and we were both new and it
was only myself Alf and Patrick I think
and Alfie knighted meant on the plane so
I said of that the most nerve-racking I
think was when I went for the
read-through that was pretty terrifying
because there's so many people that I
recognized from season one I just try
and be cool just there's like there's
like all the people for the you know
from the show I was trying not to be a
bit of a bit too starstruck but yeah it
was fine once we've got the first day of
the read-through it's great yeah there's
a big cast of actors isn't it yeah the
table read was epic it was a huge room
and it's cameras everywhere and they go
their official HBO people and then liked
it please have the words come out right
yeah but no pressure then no exactly no
pressure
yeah but no it was absolutely fine and
everyone was really welcoming and lovely
it couldn't have been a nicer experience
or any from start to finish now although
it's the show that some people might
think oh it's quite a male-dominated
lots of male characters you know it's
about war and things like that there
were very strong female characters on
the show aren't that of which you are
one say what does that feel like I am
one yeah actually till I don't have that
perception listeners have a lot been
very male-dominated but I suppose
because I've I'm a girl and I focus on
is because Maisie and Sophie Lena and
Michelle
Gwendolyn and myself I'm sure I'm
missing people were like with everyone's
really strong and female characters
wasn't it no one's lying down and taking
it poor old Sophie and I just taking a
bit of birth sure she'll come good but
yeah it's um was wonderful to play such
a really feisty strong
character absolutely kind of things you
drawing on for that you bit of a feisty
character bit with tough cookie or you
or of a soft Center that's a really good
question I don't know what I'm I suppose
I'm yeah I it's a really good question I
think in real life I am quite soft but
maybe some people that I know wouldn't
say that I know I want basically and I
can't be a bit stubborn and quite
headstrong yeah but um yeah I'm very
patient as well so let's balance out
yeah your character study knows what she
wants on the show doesn't she and she
kind of goes to almost any lengths
definitely talking about how she
mentioned
beyond character before yeah my
introduction to him and him to me yeah
the fact that she would go to any
lengths is quite fantastic chose to just
set that part of my character up
immediately like this woman will go to
any lengths for what she's worked really
hard for and what she wants and what she
knows she deserves and or she thinks she
deserves I suppose but um yeah that was
that was quite shocking when I did the
read when I when I've got the script
first off for now so who's this s great
girl that's great and Yara there's two
characters but I've got to read for them
both and then only in the casting room
did I find out oh oh right that's my bro
oh wow she really is something anything
so yeah I said it's just great how do
you feel about her as a character and
what do you think fans feel about her as
a character in terms of how she appears
um I think I think it's kind of a nice
starting point and I obviously a submit
in the next talking point that I get
funded on a horse if he to put it mildly
but I think people are quite shocked and
and yeah impressed like such a bold
statement was made so so early on and
that she's strong and like I only get
really nice feedback about like how how
I'm portraying it largely I mean I'm
sure this people who would think
differently but yeah it's always been
really positive everyone seems to be
behind the choices that were made for
her on my behalf and and from me for her
so yeah it's kind of like a girl power
burial isn't it with her you know cuz
obviously
Theon's been away she's the one
inheriting the powers that she which I
guess would have been his place it had
been there so what would you like to see
happen in future oh and I like to see
happen what do I know he's gonna happen
what would I like to see I would like to
see that I think I would like her to get
what she once go back to the earlier
what I said I was a softy no I'm not
actually I think she really needs to get
what she's worked for because yeah he's
been away for nine years and he's come
back and all these dresses and baubles
and I don't know but I think I think
still Yara does she does yeah sure sorry
and she does really connects deal with
Theon on a fundamental level I think
she's still like Baylin has given up on
him but I think I really still believe
in him and he could he could just turn
but maybe he does maybe he doesn't
tune in and find out I what's it like
working with without being Patrick II
work to the far didn't he was your dad
as he said yeah it was brilliant from
from the get-go I met our fezzes a
earlier on the plane over to the
read-through and we hit it off
immediately which is great and yeah we'd
had most of our scenes together I think
and then a couple with Patrick and
Patrick is so funny so dry and funny and
just an old pro you really like he just
oozes this of charisma and he looks like
he's doing nothing and then you watch it
in when broadcast you're like oh my god
there's so much so he's doing so much
and yet so little he was really
wonderful to work with and very very
funny and kind yeah tell me a little bit
about the locations from working with a
small he got some great ones on Game of
Thrones a bit yeah yeah some great
locations although I'm in the casting
breakdown initially it said do you know
this character it goes to like Iceland
and Croatia oh yeah they're on my hit
list my kid she doesn't just stayed in
Belfast which is actually beautiful we
went to went up the antrum coding it was
my favorite part and
just along from the Giant's Causeway and
it was just spectacular really really
beautiful and they go to absolutely any
lengths to get the most beautiful
location even if you have to sort of
trek through grasses along a cliff
but quite a long time in your costume
just to get on a horse to ride a little
bit up a hill but yeah yeah it was it's
great just always astounded at the
lengths that were reached to get the
very best I suppose it's really clear
and he said about the costumes though
what's it like wearing those clothes
especially when you are like trekking
along the hillside is it well I think
the clothes are as you can see they're
incredible and they're as good quality
as they look I mean my costume was very
very lucky they make them for you and so
it's all kind of bespoke so it fit me
very well but there's there's kind of a
breastplate that I sometimes worn in
episode 8 of a season 2 I was sitting in
that lot the long table like you know
telling Theon you know what he's done is
really not kind of work out for him and
then and this breastplate cigar was just
squeaking nice trying to keep really
still and still look really mean and
like discipline him but try and stay
still same time it was so we fixed I
think with some BlueTEC was a table
something anyway that stopped smoking
but yeah I know the costumes are
fantastic and then when you get that big
cloak on and stuff and they just
yeah the attention to detail and they
had the hand hand work that's gone into
it yeah it's not called hand work is
there what's it called when he hadn't
hand sewing the hand work or the sewing
all of the questions a hand studied and
yeah and then some would have to come
maybe half an hour before we were due to
go to set to tie me and this this lacing
it goes down my thing yeah goes down my
thing demonstrated where it was then why
am i this in leather trousers and
leather kind of grows when you're sort
of moving around in heating my trousers
kind of kept falling down she wasn't
really like the warrior princess that I
was going for so I had to underneath my
question have a big pair of like man
braces like secrets behind the instep
say you had a creaky over
and in a pair of large braces did the
check and no one would know I thought
you were gonna say earlier or you or
something no no no they didn't oil me I
didn't have a lot of oil in my hair but
not in my armor no now we've talked
about costumes and occasions I mean in
terms of what you've done so far in
terms of season one and two which you've
seen but have been your favorite moments
oh my favorite moments let me see I
think my Isis very you have very
difficult to choose I think guys the
Antrim coast because it was just such a
stunning location and actually the first
day on set we did we shut out a sequence
so he shot episode 8 before any of my
other scenes and so I was quite a big
scene as well as I was rather nervous
and rather like overwhelmed and yeah
that was one of my favorite days I
suppose it's so it's just so clear what
it would add what a big operation it was
I suppose and it was yeah it's quite
taken aback she has a lot to deal with
doesn't she know you're in the show how
do you think you'd make out in her
situation cuz it's a bit of a tough
world isn't it it is a very tough world
I think I'd be alright you know I think
I'd be alright I think um yeah it's very
clear what has to be done
I'll just go about it get what I want do
what you have to do yeah I think I do
alright when I said Troy how'd you get
under her skin as a character as well um
a lot of it comes from the writing it's
it's all there for you to know what she
is and how she is and and also the books
I referred to the books quite a lot and
Wikipedia and the answer to all
questions the answer to all questions
Wikipedia and I had some friends who are
big fans of the books and they took me
through it and talked to me about her
stuff and yeah I suppose there must be
some element of those characteristics in
me yeah so I found it alright actually
it was she was easy to access inserts in
some ways because it's so well written
yeah and speaking of the books have you
kept up today are you ahead where are
you in them well I read the first book
and then I read all the relevant bits of
my character sorry but I plan to read
the book
I promise but yeah it was just a bit
much I think I got the job a month
before I went out to Belfast and so so
started speed reading the first book and
then I did all the Wikipedia and just
relevant chapters and stuff so yeah I'm
nowhere near up to date but I understand
from many people that oh you know when I
was gonna be your character and give you
that kind of mmm
so I don't know I just met someone
reception actually issues that yeah
we'll have to have a talk later because
she goes through some stuff so yeah my
my nudity clause might need to be
changed things that might happen on the
show now I know there's been some quite
spectacular deaths and unexpected death
for people having them I mean it really
goes there isn't it now if you had to
get chopped on the show how do you like
to go oh I think she'd go by axe
wouldn't she some sort of axe disaster
yeah where yeah I think something epic
with an axe the big fight against a man
that would be nice like she's really
trying to prove herself or maybe maybe
it goes wrong and I know you're working
on other stuff at the moment as well
tell us a little about that um I just
finished a run in the West End of a play
called one man two governors and I
finished that last week and then I'm now
doing my stand-up show again in a couple
of weeks time at the Leicester Square
Theatre so yeah I was doing that on the
seventh and eighth of February and yeah
I guess I'm going up a few meetings and
bits and bobs we expect in terms of your
standard kind of style are you do you
compare yourself to Lord I don't know
who I compare myself to you because I do
character she's called chastity
Butterworth and so she's like I sort of
strange incongruous Victorian lady so I
don't know if I'd compare to anybody
really but um yeah she's just kind of an
odd and it'll add character who sort of
decided she might take ups and stand up
and it's worked out quite well nicely so
far so I haven't done my show for a long
time saying
it's something you've done in the past
so if you didn't have you didn't lost
under before I've done a lot of stand-up
before and I prepared this show that I'm
going to do again I've read of Edinburgh
two years ago but then I got Game of
Thrones I could go and then I was in the
play last year sighs I thought maybe I
just dust it off and at least try again
because I love doing it I really do this
comedy is very dear to me so yeah I've
done it before and I'm hoping to
continue what we're looking for were in
terms of costume and things for that are
you in a Victorian Sutra and my mum made
me a skirt my best friend at me a blouse
and yeah it's just a little skirt and
blouse combination and she's just
terribly twee looking yeah so you can
see you on which dates per second the
7th and 8th the February god this is
shameless the Leicester Square fits it's
called chastity Butterworth in the
Spanish hamster there is no Spanish
hamster India I'm sorry but it just
seemed like a funny title I like the
title so hamster fans hamster fans and
and chastity fans sounds wrong and on
that bombshell gone really well
lots of luck with that and and we look
forward to your CCS and trio game of
Thrones - thank you very much really
nice to talk to you
you